hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint moins vite
sur messenger
[Musique]
bonjour m'émerveille je vois laptop et
d'autre la la la la
ici et là j'ai plus qu'à ma musique et
l'ex pink parade
[Musique]
on y va on va se retrouver très vite et
vive la france et vive le charles de
gaulle à hem et y en a plus si on fait
bien
quoi
d'ici là je vais jeter car il faut que
j'envoie le 20 janv walpen un frère
[Musique]
life et la laïcité live
hamilton c'est bizarre avec ses bords
merde alors on découvre dès la reprise
un nouvel artiste qui s'appelait la
fanatique
on va la pécho évidemment la coupe du
monde
le poc il faut jamais tenir en laisse
moscou résonance à la russie
architecture j'attaque la donne au genou
mais la bande-annonce route il a bien la
voix ce matin est ce que j'ai un film
était un problème nouveau
mais non tu vois un peu du matin pour
zizi du matin mais sympa
[Musique]